à la lumière des événements de ces 12
derniers mois
j'ai peut-être plus de matière à
réflexion que les autres années
[Musique]
la famille royale traverse une véritable
crise
[Musique]
on a le royaume ont-ils nuit à la
réputation de ce pays
la maison des Windsor devrait unir la
nation elle devrait donner l'exemple
d'une vie de famille idéale
cette situation ne peut affecter la
stabilité de notre nation
ça fait des années que j'en appelle à
une monarchie plus moderne qui soit en
phase avec le monde je ne crois pas que
ce soit mon comportement qui menace sa
survie vous en tant que futur roi avait
un devoir
les gens ne pourraient jamais savoir ce
que j'ai réellement traversé
[Musique]
je n'avais pas la moindre chance
elle est au bord de l'implosion à cause
de la façon dont elle pense avoir été
traitée il la voit comme une menace
[Musique]
n'oubliez pas de respecter une condition
la seule règle à observer
demeurer loyal à cette famille
voulait dire me taire oui c'est un
système pour le meilleur ou pour le pire
nous sommes tous coincés dedans j'ai
l'impression que tout est sur le point
d'exploser
il suffit qu'elle ouvre la bouche et
elle lance des grenades elle veut
détruire le temple vous avez le feu vert
n'est plus question que je me taise je
me battrai jusqu'au bout
sa gloire appartient au passé
le monde va évoluer son
il ne restera rien
[Musique]
comment on est arrivé là